the only arrivals at manchester victoria
this morning came under their own steam
there were no trains to disturb the
peace the station shut down almost
completely on day one of the first
national rail strike in 30 years
it's just after eight at manchester
victoria it's peak rush hour well not
this morning the only service running at
all is the tram serving the city usually
this would be full of passengers coming
in and out of leeds and liverpool but
today there's nothing
it was a similar picture across the
country with london underground shut
down fewer than 20 of overground
services running anywhere and large
chunks of the country cut off to the
inconvenience of many there's no way i
work from home i have to get to work but
now that everything has been disrupted
you know at the end of the day the end
goal is to get better pay in better
conditions and if this is what we have
to do and and i support the workers then
that's what has to be done we're going
to cambridge tomorrow to see a building
um
we're going to go by train but we're
going to drive now working people have
the right to stand up for themselves and
if they don't feel that they're being
offered
the right deal then i think anybody's
got the right to to strike as up to 50
000 rmt members walked out in a dispute
over paying conditions the blame game
resumed the prime minister suggesting
commuters should expect a long haul we
need the union barons to sit down with
net network network rail and the train
companies and and get on with it and
we need i'm afraid everybody and i say
this to the to the country as a whole
and we need to get ready to to stay
the course grant traps can come to the
table if he wants i'm not particularly
bothered but if he wants to come to the
table he'd be welcome as long as he
comes in a framework of goodwill what he
needs to do really is allow the
management of the train operating
companies and network rail the license
to get on with negotiating but while
there was disruption fears this solstice
strike would be the longest day for
travellers two were unfounded
transport for greater manchester say
road traffic was up just 2 percent
despite 80 percent of trains being
cancelled primed by the pandemic this
was the day millions stayed at home
at this environmental consultants covid
accelerated a culture of flexible
working so when the strike was announced
they knew what to do it hasn't really
affected me today i'm i'm working from
home i've chosen to work from home today
so
it's pretty easy for me to just log on
as i did through the pandemic working
from home
talks between network rail and the rmt
will resume on wednesday but services
will remain disrupted ahead of further
strikes that will come at a price for
city centre businesses and test public
patience and the appetite for compromise
paul kelso sky news in manchester